انتهت الانتخابات الرئاسية تقريبًا الآن ، كان أحد المرشحين في هذا السباق ، الرئيس دونالد ترامب غير أمين إلى حد كبير ، وقد أدلى المرشح الآخر ، نائب الرئيس السابق ، جو بايدن ، بادعاءات كاذبة وليس هناك أي عذر لذلك ، ولكن كان هناك عدد أقل بكثير بالنسبة لي. ثلاثة مواضيع كان ترامب فيها مخادعًا بشكل فاضح ، الأول هو جائحة الفيروس التاجي ، نحن نقلب الزاوية التي نقلبها مثل مضمار السباق ، انظر إلى هذا ، إنه مثالي ، سيختفي ، وكما أقول `` إعادة تدوير المنعطف الذي نقربه عند الزاوية ، إنه يذهب بعيدًا ، وهذا عكس الصحيح ، إنه مثل انعكاس للواقع لأعلى يمثل انعكاسًا للأسفل ولأنه لا أساس له تمامًا طوال الأشهر الثمانية التي كرر فيها ترامب نفس حالات الادعاء التي ضربت الجميع- الوقت القياسي يرتفع عدد مرات دخول المستشفى مرة أخرى ، حيث يرتفع معدل إيجابية الاختبار ، ويزداد عدد الوفيات مرة أخرى ، ويزداد الوضع سوءًا  البريد في الولايات المتحدة ،
الموضوع الثاني الذي أعتقد أن
ترامب كان غير نزيه بشكل فاضح
هو البريد في التصويت ، لقد بذل ترامب
جهدًا ثابتًا لمحاولة زائفة
لإقناع الناس
بأن التصويت عبر البريد مليء بالاحتيال في
بعض الأحيان حتى أنه يستشهد
بأمثلة خيالية شاهد  شاهد تلك البطاقات ،
شاهد ما يجري ،
فأنت أكثر أهمية من أي عين
وتراقب سلطات إنفاذ القانون ،
حسنًا ، هل شاهدت ، هل رأيت
50.000 بطاقة اقتراع في مثل النهر ،
ولم يتم العثور على أوراق اقتراع في النهر ،
ناهيك عن 50000 بطاقة اقتراع  تم اختراع هذا بالكامل
، وفي حالات الاحتيال العامة مع التصويت بالبريد
نادر جدًا ،
فإن الموضوع الثالث الذي كان ترامب
شديد الفظاعة هو ما يمثله بايدن
في الكلام بعد أن
عزا ترامب المواقف إلى بايدن
التي لا يحملها بايدن في
الواقع في  بعض المواقف التي
رفضها صراحة هنا هي فقط واحدة منهم
يريدون الذهاب إلى الطب الاجتماعي والاختلاط
بالطب والذهاب إلى المستشفى
والعناية بك  إذا تخلصت من 180
مليون
خطة خاصة يحبها الناس ، فقد كان بايدن في
الواقع معارضًا
صريحًا لخطط نقل الجميع إلى
التأمين الصحي العام ، فهو يعمل على
خيار عام يمكن للناس فيه
اختيار برنامج تأمين عام طواعية
إذا أرادوا الآن تقديم العطاءات.  قام بنفسه
بتسليم بعض الأشخاص المهملين خلال
الانتخابات التمهيدية الديمقراطية ، فقد ظل يروي
قصة مخترعة حول كيفية اعتقاله مرة واحدة
في جنوب إفريقيا أثناء
محاولته زيارة نيلسون مانديلا في السجن
، واعترف لاحقًا
بأن ذلك لم يحدث ، واستمر في
تقديم تاريخ تنقيحي غير دقيق للغاية
عن  دعمه الأولي لحرب العراق
في الانتخابات العامة على الرغم من أن
بايدن كان أفضل في الغالب من حيث النص في
الغالب ،
إلا أنه لا يزال يقدم بعض
الادعاءات الكاذبة ، هل سمعت من قبل أن هذا الرئيس يقول
شيئًا سلبيًا واحدًا
عن العنصريين البيض ، هل
سمعته من قبل
هذا هو السبب  لقد عدت إلى هذا
السباق لأنه من العدل الآن بالتأكيد أن
نتساءل عن رد ترامب على
تفوق البيض  sts وعنفهم ،
لكن ليس صحيحًا أن ترامب لم
يقل شيئًا سلبيًا واحدًا عنهم أو
لم يدينهم أبدًا
في الواقع لقد أدانهم ترامب في
مناسبات متعددة
.
جاءت معظم المزاعم الكاذبة الفاضحة في المناظرة الرئاسية الأخيرة ، حيث
كان ترامب يتحداه بشأن تعليقاته السابقة
حول التكسير الهيدروليكي
، وقال بايدن إنه لم يجعلها أبدًا
الرئيس
لم يقل أبدًا أنني أعارض frackie الذي قلته
على شريط ، لقد
عرضت الشريط وضعه على موقع الويب الخاص بك.
سأضعها على
الموقع الإلكتروني ، حقيقة الأمر هي أنها
مستلقية الآن ، فإن ترامب خاطئ عندما يقول أن
بايدن لديه خطة لإنهاء جميع عمليات التكسير التكسير ،
في الواقع يعمل بايدن على خطة
لإنهاء عقود الإيجار الجديدة للنفط والغاز
في الأراضي والمياه العامة على وجه الخصوص ،
لكن بايدن أعرب
خلال الانتخابات التمهيدية الديمقراطية عن
معارضة عامة للتكسير ،
وهذا ما يوضحه الشريط أنه سيكون هناك
أي مكان للوقود الأحفوري  بما في ذلك
الفحم والتكسير الهيدروليكي
في إدارة بايدن ، لا ، بل سنعمل على حلها ،
سنتأكد من إزالته وعدم وجود المزيد من
الإعانات لأي من هذين
الوقود الأحفوري ، لذا كان دونالد
ترامب أسوأ بكثير
من حملة جو بايدن  من منظور الصدق
ولكن بايدن بالتأكيد لم
يكن مثاليًا أيضًا